[Music]
the first thing i want to do is get a
sense of your time inside and
specifically how trans inmates affected
your experience i was incarcerated with
trans individuals and provincial that
was the first time i came across it
and then again when i went to federal
um and that was when they actually put
them on compound with us instead of
segregating them away from us
and they didn't have to have surgery so
that happened in 2017
and what was your reaction when you
learned that there were trans inmates
living in the compound with you well i
was actually really freaked out in
provincial because they brought me over
to the indirect supervision range and
there was a sex offender there that was
fully intact
and he was there hiding out because of
his crimes
um that's what the guards told me
anyways but he was trying to peek into
my cell when they were strip searching
me
um
so that was my very first experience of
that but when i got to federal and i was
told that there were men on compound
with us i was blown away i didn't
believe it
i couldn't believe that they were
putting males in women's prisons i was
sexually harassed by one of them when i
was inside used to get me to try to walk
back and forth in front of them so that
they could check out my butt
um lots of other comments as well
and then i was also in the halfway house
with a male who was fully intact and it
was like walking on eggshells we got
into a few like um
altercations just like um
verbally
but there there are more now that i have
transferred that have been in with my
friends
um and women that i've been inside with
are you worried that there are people
who are going to
use the system in order to end up in a
female prison and then come out and
decide that he's a man again
well yeah there's nothing to prevent
them if they claim transgender
identity
you can't
say that they're not transgender because
you're discriminating against their
identity or their expression and even
the ones that do get denied transfer
they're utilizing the grievance system
which is a complaint system for
correctional services of canada and when
their complaint's not resolved they're
bringing it to the human rights tribunal
so
when they win these cases it opens the
door to what's going on with the united
states right now
so
they get to hear their cases heard how
about you did you ever inform the guards
about how uncomfortable you felt or that
incident that you described of sexual
assault and if so how did they react
so as women we do not utilize
the avenues that are set out for us so
the grievance system and the human
rights tribunal um we're just not we're
not taught about it we don't understand
how the system works and for the most
part women are
they're they're dealing with so much
trauma like a lot of them are like
prostitution drug addiction and have
been abused their entire lives they just
accept it as another thing that's
happened to them it's reality of being
female
so
there are complaints and there are
grievances but not enough women are
speaking out because they're scared
did any of your fellow female prisoners
have similar experiences to you
yes um some of my friends were like
pushed up against the wall in the
laundry room and had tongues shoved down
their throats they've had
their breasts or their butt touched
sexual comments
a few of them have been sexually
assaulted
so i speak to a lot of women that have
been
incarcerated and the stories are very
similar same with physical altercations
they've never been punched in the face
so hard
they're starting to carry weapons around
which is not a normal thing for women
that are incarcerated in canada so
they're putting soup cans and socks
because they know that they're fighting
males and not women and there's the
really really big power difference
between them
canada's prison system allows men to
choose to serve their sentence in a
female prison if they say they identify
as women they don't need to undergo any
surgery or hormone therapy their word is
enough the authorities say this is in
the name of equality and to ensure the
safety of transgenders the law change
was pushed for by prime minister justin
trudeau himself will you do your best to
ensure that trans women are put in
prison
or prison more appropriate to their
gender identity
um
the answer is yes um
i will ensure that i consider myself to
be a fairly strong advocate for for lgbt
q2 issues and and uh fairly
aware of all the different pressures and
this wasn't one that i had ever thought
of so thank you
heather mason whom we just heard from
says the government has to rethink its
approach to the whole issue nobody wants
to speak about it they don't want to
report on it we're being told that we're
lying that it's not happening that we
have bigoted views that were transphobic
there's literally no discussion about it
there is no discussion before
any of the policies that were
implemented
and i feel like there are solutions to
this they have the room in men's
institutions that have wings and dorms
and they can make lgbtq wings that are
tailored to fit their unique needs
because their needs are different than
women's needs
so they have the room they don't have to
build prisons and then they can take
care of the entire community and not
just the select few that are being
transferred into the women's prison
right now but also there are trans men
so those are females who identify as men
and they're denied transfers due to
overriding health and safety concerns
because it's not safe in men's prisons
so this is a one-sided policy that only
benefits males who still have their
penis because we took males who have had
surgery since at least 1982.
over in the united states similar
concerns have been raised for example by
the case of jania monroe a transgender
woman in illinois who was transferred
from a men's prison to a women's
facility that was after she alleged male
inmates had sexually harassed her but in
her new prison monroe herself was
accused of raping a female inmate at the
start of the year california passed its
own controversial law now it allows
trans inmates to be transferred to
facilities that align with their gender
identity the law was adopted in january
and by may over 260
transfer requests had been made and
that's left some female convicts very
worried
i will not be a victim anymore i have
endured sexual abuse as young as four to
eight and with the rape as well as
numerous male staff correctional
officers being inappropriate ever since
california's sb 132 has passed i have
been living in constant fear i can't
mentally function without fear if the
men come here please help us i'm scared
just because they feel like a woman
doesn't mean their penis doesn't work
we discuss california's law with alexa
haron a co-founder of partners for
ethical care and founder of the gender
mapping project she says the well-being
of women prisoners is simply of no
interest to legislators
senate bill 132
is is is like i say it's sentencing
women who have committed whatever crime
to the punishment of sexual violence at
the hands of males and i think that in
terms of the pyramid of needs
uh
gavin newsom and scott weiner and every
other enabler who has allowed this to
happen views the feelings of and the
physical safety of incarcerated women at
the bottom of that pyramid of needs when
we of course understand it has to be at
the top
rt's keeping a close eye on similar
developments in the u.s and elsewhere in
the world and will have more features on
the issues raised to come
[Music]
you